all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here he is suited up ready to go got the
tie on must be uh must be an important
day obviously uh let's start with uh the
kiss portfolio construction method this
something you guys have helped the
Pioneer and I think is uh you know
showing now why it works but talk to us
about kiss and what exactly that means
yeah appreciate that man thanks thanks
again for having me on TI Ties on for
now for the institutional client
meetings but for your party later uh
we'll keep the ties off for for that uh
so looking forward to that man thanks
again for the
uh so in terms of our kids portfolio
construction process um this is our
Flagship uh portfolio construction
process that we market and maintain for
for clients of 42 macro um it was really
born out of our pivot to transitory
Goldilocks back in January where we
decided to stop shorting assets all
together uh we had um actually we had qu
quite a tough Q4 last year you know kind
of getting squeezed and ultimately went
to the drawing board and really tried to
lean on uh some of the you know kind of
core institutional learnings that I've
I've I've developed throughout the
course of my career in terms of
developing this process and what it's
ultimately designed to do is help
investors your traditional money
managers traditional investors regular
retail investors outperform 6040 over
the long term by introducing Trend
following elements into that strategy
and more importantly introducing a
permanent allocation to bitcoin as a
traditional asset class in that
strategy now when you do this you don't
just create something out of thin air
and say we think it works you obviously
back test you go and you try to figure
out how effective has this actually been
talk a little bit about the back testing
and what those results really have shown
yeah 100% man absolutely so this thing's
been rolling live since uh since January
um obviously when we back test anything
here at 42 macro it's all with all the
you know understandings and and the
understandings of you know what the
proven quantitative techniques are in
the business and and ultimately
everything we construct is on an out of
sample uh basis in terms of back testing
but there's a couple of highlights I
throw in you in terms of our our kiss
portfolio construction process uh so
kiss which is again a
60310 portfolio construction that
features spy as the equity portion a as
the fixed income portion uh and bitto at
least for now until we get a Bitcoin ETF
which we think is likely to be approved
in the coming months U for now as the as
the Bitcoin allocation which allows you
know again retail investors traditional
Raa type investors uh and family offices
really to to gain access uh to what we
believe are are positive diversification
benefits for Bitcoin as an inclusion in
that asset class so just going back to
Performance we actually have a chart I
sent to you you can throw it up on the
screen uh for production um where we
show the hypothetical performance of a
$100,000 portfolio since January 2018
both in a on a on on a raw basis but
also in terms of you know the
performance over industry standard
reporting Horizons and what we find is
that kiss as it's currently constructed
featuring our Trend following elements
as well as our top- down and bottom up
risk management overlays which we'll
talk about in a second um has a sharp
ratio of about 0.9 which is more than
double which is about double 6040 or the
double the sharp ratio of just being
long 60 30 10 spy a Bitcoin uh in
isolation without those top down and
bottom up risk management overlay
elements you know if you look at the
chart on the right you see that kiss our
kiss our portfolio construction process
which is our Flagship uh asset
allocation process here 42 macro is
outperforming 6040 on any you know
relevant duration and even outperforming
the uh 60310 raw approach uh on any
relevant duration in sense exception and
then one thing i' would say I'm most
proud of is the the the Max draw down
statistics the risk management
statistics because again it's not enough
to just being able to be long assets any
any monkey with you know a blind monkey
with you know peanut butter on a Tans uh
could could be long assets it's about
keeping the money you make in asset
markets uh for the and having money to
invest for the next cycle and what we
find is that you know in these back
tests you know the Max draw down for our
kiss our flagship K portfolio
construction process which again
includes 60301 spy a and Bitcoin and top
down and bottom up R management overlays
there in the Max draw down for that
process is only minus 10% and there's
only one double- digigit draw down that
minus 10% since the beginning of 2018
you compare that to 6040 the Mac they've
had three Max draw Downs in 6040 since
the beginning of 2018 that Eclipse minus
10% um there's a minus 12.5% draw down
in Q4 2018 there's a minus 22% draw down
in Co and there was a minus uh 22% draw
down uh at the lows in October of 2022
and then that also Compares our minus
10.6% Max draw down statistic Compares
extremely favorably uh to the 60310 raw
poach which takes that 60310 spy a
Bitcoin allocation and does not include
our bottom up and top down risk
management overlays and there's been
three crashes in in 60301 raw uh Bitcoin
spy a Bitcoin over the past you know
kind of five to six years it crashed in
Q4 of 2018 it crashed during Co down 23%
Peak the trough and then it crashed in
2022 down 25.3% so uh the kind of quick
summary is is that you know if you going
to add Bitcoin as a as a serious
investor as a traditional investor into
your asset allocation approach it
obviously pays to have systematic
thoughtful quantitatively oriented risk
managements to guide that process along
the way and smooth out those returns now
when you talk about risk management one
of the things that's really interesting
is everyone uh notoriously is long when
they should be short and short when they
should be long right risk management is
very very hard um when it comes to uh
just the economic machine different
asset classes different geographies
different rate environments uh and the
complexity just grows from there you all
have this macro weather uh model that
you're really using to try to understand
all these different inputs talk a little
bit about how does that model work and
then what are some of the things that
you guys pay attention to that may tell
you hey now is uh uh some time we should
be paying attention to some sort of risk
management whether top or bottoms up
yeah great question man and so yeah we
absolutely so uh our weather model macro
weather model is one of our Flagship
models that we use here 42 macro uh to
help uh our primarily our Institutional
Investor client base understand the the
you know the rolling three-month forward
excess return dispersion environment and
volatility environment of cross asset
classes and we ultimately use that that
information to construct Target
allocation sizes in that kiss portfolio
construction process and so what this
what this model is designed to do is
actually uh regime segment all the
principal components of macro whether
you look at the the real economy Cycles
between growth inflation employment
corporate profits and fiscal policy or
whether you isolate the financial
economy Cycles looking at liquidity
credit interest rates and positioning
and it's designed again to regime
segment each of those core features of
the economy and asset markets and
ultimately project uh the excess return
and volatility characteristics that
those regimes you know currently um
currently project into each asset class
and so you know kind of just a quick
summary of the model right now based on
the current constellation of signals as
is as indicated by the component
features in the model things like our
net liquidity model which is so popular
across Global Wall Street that balance
sheet TG RP y y y our Global liquidity
proxy which is will soon to be very
popular across Global Wall Street
because that's a better uh better model
you know things like growth things like
inflation you know the fiscal deficit
you know aggregated positioning in the
treasury market there's all these
different features in the model that are
each contributing independently to the
excess return dispersion projection for
each asset class and right now what the
what the model is saying is that over
the next three months in the stock
market an investor is is is is right to
expect higher returns and lower
volatility relative to the Baseline
return and volatility profile for that
particular asset class over the next
three months that care condition is is
shared by the bond market and that
condition is also shared uh by the by
the Bitcoin Market as well the dollar
and commodity signals are neutral and
and and so going back to our kiss
portfolio construction process you know
how we Implement these weather model
signals into that process is visit the
top down risk management overlay
actually if you throw that first chart
back up on the screen where we show you
know if the weather model signal for the
stock market for instance is bullish the
target exposure for the Spy is 60% if
that weather model signal for the stock
market is neutral the target exposure
for the Spy is 50% the weather model
signal for the Spy is bearish uh for the
stock market is bearish and the target
exposure for the spy in This 60310 Kiss
profol construction process is only 40%
and and so we we according in the sizes
of those Target exposures up and Down
based on the rolling three-month forward
return and volatility projections as
indicated uh by the signals generated by
our macro weather model now let's talk
liquidity management because I think
this is another big piece of it
obviously uh when we look at short-term
treasuries and things like that people
are constantly trying to figure out
should I be holding cash should I be
holding treasuries since there's some
other asset that I could hold um
liquidity how do you think about it and
what are exactly people doing inside of
this portfolio yeah great question P so
there's a two things so there's two
types of liquidity right right uh
there's the liquidity in your portfolio
you know in terms of the cash you have
in your portfolio that allows you to buy
more assets um obviously if you're maxed
long in any given time you're not unable
to do so unless you have new cash
injections and then there's the
liquidity that tends to drive asset
markets higher and lower over the you
know medium and long term uh in terms of
things like Central Bank liquidity
private sector liquidity coming from
commercial Banks or non-bank Market
participants or whether it be liquidity
that we uh see you know spill over into
Reserve treasury markets Visa res ve
manager so those are two types of
liquidity uh the F the second type of
liquidity I.E you know net liquidity
Global liquidity the stuff that's
currently helping Bitcoin accelerate uh
in price uh is obviously being captured
Again by our weather model signal which
is ultimately being you know influencing
um you know the excess return dispersion
volatility projections from that from
that uh from that model uh the bottomup
risk management overlay in our kiss 6310
kiss portfolio construction process
which again features Bitcoin as a core
element um is is really born out of what
we call our volatility adjusted momentum
signal uh so that's just fany fancy you
know yell man yell lingo for saying hey
we use a volatility overlay to give us a
better opportunity to project whether or
not the current conditions in momentum
are likely to be sustained over the
medium term and right now if you look at
um you know the charts we prepared for
you uh the spy Spy ETF which again that
6030 that 60 anchor and that 60310
approach is currently bullish from the
perspective of our volatil adjusted
momentum signal and so the actual
exposure
Visa the bottomup risk management
overlay in This Kiss portfolio
construction process equals 100% of its
Target allocation which we said earlier
is currently 60% because of that bullish
weather model signal uh the the actual
exposure for the a ETF is also uh
equivalent to 100% of its Target
allocation uh because again this the a
ETF is is bullish in so much that the
Bitcoin ETF is also bullish as well so
each of these core components of our
60310 portfol construction process are
currently bullish from the perspective
of volatility adjust momentum signal
which means we are from a dynamic
position sizing perspective in terms of
our Trend following approach we are at
Max long exposure from a dynamic
position sizing perspective if any one
of these ETFs went down to neutral then
those positions will get cut in half
from the perspective of that dynamic
position sizing process and any one of
these ETFs broke down to bearish from
the perspective of that volatility
adjusted momentum signal we'd see that
dynamic position process cut those
positions to 0% and what that's designed
to do is help investors who are you know
investing alongside our kiss portfol
construction process it helps them
maximize upside capture in Bull markets
which we are currently doing for our
clients all around the world thousands
of investors around the world here at 42
macro but it also the top down and
bottom up RIS management overlays helps
them minimize downside capture in bare
markets by taking down their target
allocations when the macro weather model
is saying hey you know they're poor
they're bad times ahead for each
independent asset class or when the
bottom up RIS management overlay kicks
in and says okay this particular
exposure uh is telling you that there's
more left tail risk in the months ahead
based on our volatil just momentum
signal so uh it's a complex process but
it's not a complicated process because
it's extremely easy to implement as a
retail investor or an RA investor
because you're only talking about ever
having to risk manage three ETFs at any
one time my last question for you is I
think the question on Wall Street right
now uh Jerome Powell he's got uh you
know two fingers
increase rates decrease rates uh which
one's he going to hit are we going to
get the bill Aman q1 rate cut the
Market's pricing in 100% by the end of
Q2 uh Bitcoin folks the crazi on the
internet they're all buying Bitcoin
because they think rate cuts are coming
like tomorrow uh what what happens and
when should we expect to kind of see
lower rates uh coming into the market
well the low rates are already in the
market right if you look at uh Market
imply projections as you mentioned uh
you know whether you look at overnight
index swaps or fed funds Futures uh
there's a tremendous amount of policy
rate easing priced into 2024 um
obviously we're going to get to a you
know overwhelming consensus on the sort
of soft Landing expectations in the
market and the reason we believe markets
have coalesced around the soft Landing
expectation is because stocks are bonds
are going up at the same time uh if you
had a no Landing expectation in the
market you'd see stocks higher bonds
lower if you saw a hard Landing
expectation in the market you'd see
bonds higher stocks lower so the mere
fact that both asset classes are
positively correlating still tells you
that investors are currently really you
know centrally betting on soft Landing
as that Central uh based case um you
know in our opinion as investors I think
the average investor spends entirely too
much time predicting uh and positioning
for outcomes in the economy and not
nearly enough time reacting uh to
changes in asset markets and changes uh
in the economy as a result of the a
systematic uh investment and research
and risk management process uh that's
what we specialize in at at 42 macro we
don't specialize in saying hey the
economy is going to a soft land
therefore you must do this we think
that's a terrible way to invest and it's
more than likely the reason why so many
investors have really not made any money
over the past few years despite having
several very important and awesome
opportunities to make money as indicated
by that transitory goil loocks call we
pivoted to in January um so in our
opinion I think that to answer your
question it doesn't really matter
whether we go into a soft Landing a hard
Landing or no Landing as an investor as
an investor what matters is are you
positioned properly for Rising
expectations of a soft landing and does
that process you you that allowed you to
position properly for that will it get
you out you know with a a minimal degree
of of of downside risk at the
appropriate time once that soft Landing
expectation crescendos into a consensus
and starts migrating to something else
and in our opinion under having
processes in place to do what I just
said is way more important than
predicting the future which is why a lot
of you uh what you watching you know
continue to underperform uh you know the
broader beta in the markets now uh I
remember seeing a study by Bloomberg
that when whenever we see soft Landing
articles Spike the number of them uh
usually that is followed very quickly by
a deep recession um and so we've seen
the spike will that hold here or how are
you thinking about it yeah no I mean
look the probability of a recession in
the US economy uh and materialized over
the near term has risen in recent weeks
um you know as indicated by some of the
indicators that we track uh specifically
our 42 macro FB 5 recession signaling
indicators one of those indicators in
the last couple of weeks has breached
its recession signaling threshold so we
went from a you know call it a low
probability of a near-term recession to
a middling probability of a near-term
recession you don't have to overreact to
that as an investor because what we
found in our back testing uh in terms of
our qualitative analysis of the US
economy and INF Financial Market Cycles
is that the market tends to Peak pretty
coincident to maybe slightly ahead of
the breakout in jobs claims the
breakdown in total employment so you
don't need to put on a recession trade
you know like a year or two soon like a
lot of the guys who've not made any
money on Wall Street for the past you
know 12 to 18 months um so the reality
is you know we you you the market and
the economy and economic statistics will
give you an opportunity to get out um
ahead of a recession might not get out
at the exact highe but our goal as
investors should never to be you know
top ticking and bottom ticking asset
markets what we're trying to do is help
investors capture the maximum amount of
Trend in Bull markets and absolutely you
know be away from and and not and not
capture any of that Trend uh in bare
markets and I think we're doing a
fantastic job if only because our
research and risk management processes
are so different than the average
investor that uh that makes sense to me
we're send people to find you on the
internet or find out more about 42 macro
yeah thanks Pap I appreciate that man so
yeah we're at 42 macro.com definitely
come check us out um at Darius Dale 42
on Twitter we definitely put out a lot
of uh you know interesting educational
and helpful content out there to uh to
satisfy our audience so we just want to
say we appreciate everyone hopefully
everyone's out there having a great year
happy holidays and we'll catch you back
here in a couple weeks you are the man I
appreciate you and we'll definitely keep
doing this so well thanks so much and uh
you have a great holidays as well you
too brother thank you